distributing the coronavirus vaccine has
proven to be a major challenge
no matter what the setting but imagine
trying to get it done
across the vast sparsely populated state
of alaska
this morning we take a look at two
organizations in western alaska
that have been racing across the frozen
land to vaccinate alaskans in the thick
of winter
nancy chen introduces us to some of
those front line workers and the unique
ways
they're getting to their patients
far beyond the reaches of the nearest
connecting roads
these villages of rural alaska are only
accessible by small aircraft
or boat but there are
few latitudes too challenging for the
doctors
of the final frontier people in rural
alaska are vulnerable just like anybody
in
rural america dr katrine bengaard and
her team from the menelik association
covered northwest alaska traveling at
times
hundreds of miles a day including on
sleds pulled by snowmobiles
we caught up with vanguard during one of
her latest coronavirus vaccine runs
which started with a flight we had to
cross a river to get to town
and the river's frozen right now so um
we were able to go
just right over top of the water which
was uh kind of a fun experience and
um uh pulled up to the clinic a hop skip
and a jump
that's right their itineraries sometimes
include multiple villages in one trip
as they provide health care to 12
federally recognized tribes
their coverage area the size of indiana
was this atypical what you did today or
is this kind of a standard in order to
do healthcare this is how we get around
up here
as bengaard's team and others navigate
the rough alaskan terrain
they visit the homes of those most
vulnerable they also distribute vaccines
inside local clinics
or on their chartered single engine
planes
as well as on the tarmac patients
rolling up on snowmobiles
and hard to get out of atvs stuff isn't
it
dr alan hodges is chief of staff for the
yukon kuskokwim health corporation
which has inoculated about 6 000 people
in southwest alaska
hodges calls it a race against time to
get to as many people as possible
especially in communities where multiple
generations live together
[Music]
there are so many challenges when it
comes to getting these shots
and arms why is it worth it we have some
of the highest case rates in the nation
right now
and alaska natives are
disproportionately affected by both
hospitalizations and deaths
so getting our population which is
primarily alaska native vaccinated is my
is right now my number one priority
hodges has been a doctor in alaska for
nearly two decades
she's used to traveling to far away
villages without hospitals
but ask for a challenge like this have
you gone to these extents before
not in this exact way and not for this
exact
reason that extra effort includes
holding the delicate vaccines in her lap
on bumpy plane rights
and making sure the doses stay at the
right temperature
you can't refreeze it that destroys the
vaccine and we didn't want to erase a
drop of this precious resource so is
that right that you put it under your
shirt
yeah i tucked it into well between my
shirt and my coat to keep it warm
until right before we ejected it the
wind can freeze things
things like that really fast and then it
won't inject
the harsh and unpredictable winter days
demand creativity and nimbleness
and with the constant possibility of
getting snowed in overnight
health care workers have plenty to
juggle
just the logistics making sure that the
weather is cooperating making sure that
we have
a pilot we tried to go out to a village
yesterday and we weren't able to
get a pilot to go out that's where
community collaboration comes in
even from those who don't have medical
degrees this is probably one of the most
important trips i've ever taken
kurt jackson is a water taxi captain who
has now delivered vaccines twice
nurses boarding his 32-foot aluminum
landing craft
to cross catch a mcbay when poor weather
prevented them from flying
i immediately got kind of choked up
feeling like this is a first step
but it was also it's going to be a bumpy
ride
so a trip that normally takes us about a
half an hour
that day took us about an hour just to
slowly kind of crawl our way
across the bay um just trying to be as
gentle as
with our precious cargo as possible it's
an
effort that's paying off alaska now has
one of the highest coronavirus
vaccination rates in the country
this was hodges after the first doses
arrived this is amazing this is
wonderful i can't even tell you
i just overwhelmed how amazing this is
what struck that sense of happiness
in you you know when alaska gets dark in
the winter a lot and we slowly start
getting the light back this time of year
a few minutes every day
and that's what this vaccine feels to me
it's not automatic you know sunrise
but i tell you what every day is a
little better every shot we get in an
arm
is hopefully one less call we have to
make to tell them they have coveted
a new dawn on the horizon in a long and
difficult winter
for cbs this morning saturday nancy chen
new york there are communities all
across the country
that i'm sure could have lessons learned
from from this piece
how well they did it worth noting by the
way since it is alaska you might be
wondering why they didn't use sled dogs
which is one form of transportation
we're told that the
the ride was too rough so the vaccine
wouldn't hold up right
they can use the snowmobiles and planes
but not sled although it would have been
cool they get
to have the dogs get a vaccination from
something delivered by a sled dog right
good for them